well chances are you've heard of RSV
it's been a very serious respiratory
virus that a lot of children have been
Afflicted with and while we usually see
it common among kids through the fall
and Winters doctors say they're seeing a
surge in more serious cases and more
adults are also coming down with the
illness Sasha Loftus joining us live
from Sunrise Hospital tonight with more
Denise and Brian while RSV is nothing
new the doctor I
day here at Sunrise Hospital says it is
hitting kids and adults a bit are harder
this year it's also come about a lot
earlier he says he wants here those here
in southern Nevada to be prepared
yeah I'm concerned Dennis Conti is one
of many bracing for a busy cold and flu
season keep him healthy
and keep them
listen to your doctor another virus
seeing a surge here locally respiratory
Sensational virus or RSV we're seeing a
tremendous increase in numbers of
patients Dr David DeJean says the
illness which mainly affects children
attacks the respiratory system and can
lead to secondary infections like
pneumonia While most recover quickly at
home he says they have seen a surge in
pediatric RSV patients a tremendous
increase in hospitalizations to the
point where our pediatric Wards are
really overflowing we're having to use
non-pediatric Wards for Peds patients
CDC data shows a spike in positive cases
across the state Dr DeJean says an
unusual amount of adults are also coming
down with it this year well I think the
fact that covid was sort of taking up
all the oxygen so to speak and the other
respiratory viruses didn't really have
their chance now they're making up the
Lost times that's why he says it's
important to stay healthy get as
informed as you can and be prepared over
the next few months
I did speak with reps with Sunrise
Hospital and UMC UMC tells me while they
have seen an increase in patients with
RSV they are prepared and they do have
enough available beds now there is no
vaccine for RSV but doctors recommend of
course getting your flu or covid
vaccines if you're eligible reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now